okay so you live in a
you you live in a place of peace and a
place of joy
and caring so that's
you know kind of going to the extreme
but the subconscious
mind of freud is really
a dysfunctional part
of the consciousness what about carl
jung because carl jung might say that
the unconscious comprises
99 percent of you and that it's
impossible for you to ever be
fully conscious you're always going to
have a massive amount that's unconscious
so you defer with freud in that and
sorry jung in that respect
yeah no well they are having they're
making a very accurate
um description of people in general
people in general have lots of fear
this this uh this virtual reality virus
is a schoolhouse it's an entropy
reduction trainer
if you will and most people
haven't evolved a whole lot so there's
lots and lots of fear so freud looks at
it and he says oh ego that's a good
thing
everybody needs a healthy ego and carl
young would say yeah you're never going
to
you know you're never going to get to
the point that you know
that you don't have the shadow part of
yourself you know it's always going to
be a part of you
well it's not true it doesn't have to
always be a part of you
but it is a part of virtually everyone
because
everyone has fear and there's very few
people
that ever get rid of all that fear
so to make an analogy would be like
looking at the earth and saying all the
elements that exist are the ones that
are on the earth but they don't realize
that you can combine them and create
some that are rare yeah yeah that's just
exceptional circumstances well freud and
and jung
both were were experimentalists in a
sense they looked at people
and looked at themselves and here's what
here's what i see
here's what i see in myself here's what
i see in other people
and they're making models based on
people well
everybody almost everybody is full of
fear
there may be a few exceptions but these
are extremely rare people
so if everybody's full of fear then
everybody's going to have a shadow
and if you can't get rid of yours then
you assume that nobody can get rid of
those either